Nolan's here he says uh Tate said in
your recent podcast the best way to
start a family was to do it abroad and
keep the woman and children abroad what
if they come to your country to have the
baby how to prevent Okay so let me frame
that because
um this is a question that always comes
up I've addressed this many times uh I
just posed it to Andrew when he was on
the podcast and I think my editor made a
clip out of it so it so it's kind of
gone around you know the interwebs right
now
um and his answer to the question was
basically look if you live in Canada or
the west where it's hostile towards
fathers you want kids go to Latin
America you know say something like you
know go down to South America
have have kids over there come back home
make your money go down and visit your
kids and take care of them go back home
make your money and and handle it that
way so to this guy's question is what
happens if they come to you what happens
if she comes to
you know Canada and and she wants to
live here like I've seen guys here that
are fairly successful guys that go down
to Cuba and they'll have like a family
down there and they'll never bring them
back they'll just send money down
they'll go and visit they'll especially
go down in the winter time when it's
cold and shitty here in the wintertime
and that that's how they do it but I'm
sure Jonathan's answer is going to be
the same it's you know they come here
they stay here long enough hello you've
now invited the state into your house in
Canada or in a certain state in the U.S
and family law now applies it doesn't
matter they're now here right like would
you is that generally how it works it's
uh Nolan's question yeah that's exactly
how it works let me give you an extreme
hypothetical take it one step further
say that you live in Canada or somewhere
in the United States that's your
domicile and you have a family in Costa
Rica
and they never come here and then 10
years later they come here you still are
domiciled in the U.S or Canada
they she she could be here for less than
uh six months and file a divorce
complaint because one of the two parties
is domiciled uh here in your
jurisdiction at least in the
jurisdictions I practice one person has
to be domiciled uh for six months or
longer
so she could not be here for 10 years
then just show up one day and file for
divorce there so you really need to be
careful about that um yeah like if the
pattern has been you go down to
chili and you visit her and you come
back and you visit her and the kids and
you come back if you know if that's a
pattern and then one day you know she
shows up with the kids and she doesn't
want to leave the first thing you should
do is call your family Laura and say hey
what's up you know how does this go if
you know she's going to stay here
um so that you can prepare accordingly
because if that was your strategy to
have a family another country and and
pass on your seat and do that and take
care of them over there but she wants to
change that
um then you have to then you'll need
some time to respond accordingly but
it's a fair question I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full-length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out